few things in csgo are as hype as a nice
wallbang the anticipation as they line
up the shot the breathless moment before
they pull the trigger and boom whether
they're miraculous or calculated here
are our picks for the top 10 wall bangs
in csgo history opening our list is
Guardians wallbang on train while the
shot itself is pretty common these days
Guardian was the first to popularize it
in pro play
appropriately the shot has been
nicknamed The Guardian wallbang and he's
still pulling it off to this day living
life on the edge at number 9 is this
legendary wallbang fight get right
looking for he's got him hunted down
time is up with time ticking down to the
very last second get right lines Cajun
be up and knocks him down through the
crates to win the round ni pees reaction
is priceless
just look at this one second - going
against that kill what are the odds
boxes are no obstacle in our number
eight wallbang from this classic game
between Titan and fnatic at Dreamhack
Stockholm he's looking for the AC Scott
just seven bullets and he's gonna go for
it in the corner now it's a one-on-one
he misses a shot yes 25 seconds left and
he's got six health and he's gonna go
with a C said sprays he existance
trapped in a corner now 20 seconds oh
they win that round from start to finish
the play is a classic JW round closing
out the ace clutch with the wall bang so
smooth it could only be JW pulling it
off inheriting the legacy of get rights
hen ones ticket booth wall bang on
Mirage takes number seven it's almost
shockingly similar with the clock in its
literal last second before the shot
rings through check out the chat and
Vitas shout of disbelief let's take a
break from the ops at number six with
nothings ake a double wall bang against
fnatic join nothing I'd be up there
bragging that fantastic stuff run and
make it a double somehow it gets two
kills in that situation all of my points
back though during the summer of cloud 9
it seemed like the NA boys could do no
wrong and this wall bang is just insane
guys that'd be kind of nuts oh that's
happened that's really rare incredible
actually
yeah that's Mac alele takes number five
on our list for his wall bang on cash to
save the round with speedy sticking the
defuse next breathing down his neck and
no options left maikelele took aim at
the narrowest part of the wall and
pulled the trigger
shiipa had stopped here and you always a
shot through the box it's gonna pick up
speedy no listen again WD fees anyway
next no it blows up okay let's just
relax for sec it's just taken in a
process but we've just viewed not only
did we have no idea you could wallbang
there but to have the presence of mind
to try it it's crazy
unbelievable that he's actually won his
team that round really quite astonishing
stuff from maikelele making a second
appearance on the list hen one takes
number four for this ludicrous flick
wall bang on inferno
oh boy Jesus dude what is that what is
that most players would probably bail
after seeing a flashbang fly over the
wall but hen one reads the throw and
lands a perfect flick to pick up the
kill an instant before getting blinded
yeah this is nasty
Wow speaking of insane shots that
probably should never work number three
on the list is fallens mind-blowing
wallbang anyway that the shot literally
makes no sense but through a smoke and
through a door fallen gets the kill
anyways not much to say about this one
it's just completely absurd dear Lord in
one of the most insane plays of 2017
nifty comes in at number two for his
triple wallbang kills against tyloo in
the pgl krakow asia qualifiers since
again somebody's land hit the scout
Shawn
now this round is back the first two
shots are nice but the last one is just
impossible I don't know that I've ever
seen the stuff let's do that not an
official match have you wall banks don't
get much better than this
taking the top spot on our list is a
wall bank so ridiculous it was actually
patched out of the game as a result
[Music]
really just hit through the top of the
roof as if things couldn't go from bad
to worse that is the play of the year
just put that in then it's the epitome
of this game yes it's bodies now
infamous back to back wall banks first
is the sure Alice what are you starting
it again you can't possibly do that
twice they roll the blade completely
took over matchmaking as soon as it
happened and as a result cache was
changed to remove this wall bank spot
sadly no graffiti for body yet for this
historic play I have never seen anything
like you he's got to be just grinning
from ear to ear and there you have it
the top 10 wall bangs we couldn't
possibly put every single crazy wall
bang on the list so hit us up with your
favorite ones in the comment section
below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]